joining us here on the rich eisen show
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line
fresh off of a
wild week five game
one of the best at his position in the
national football league back here on
the rich eisen show after scoring the
game-winning touchdown that he didn't
really want to score
is austin eckler here on the rich eisen
show what's up austin
rich what's going on man thanks for
having me back have you ever been
dragged by the opposition into an end
zone before is that a first for you you
know i can honestly say i've never had a
situation where i didn't want to score a
touchdown where i could have and then
that the defense actually scored me
yes right like not even in pop warner
austin right like that's never happened
ever right yeah it's just one of those
circumstances that you you know see
a few times you know a couple years you
know
and i just happened to be there
and so on the previous play you slid
instead of going out of bounds because
you knew right you you were well aware
of
your desire to not score
correct yeah i mean i mean the idea of
it was hey let's try to use as much
clock as we can
we definitely want to score whether it
be a field goal at the last second or
run it in at the last second uh whatever
you know we had time for in the
situation but yeah we definitely wanted
to use more clock so that was the idea
of me sliding before even getting
touched and then try to do it again on
the next play and obviously they carried
me into the end zone right well did you
think about maybe take it do you ever
think of taking a neve so you didn't get
dragged in the end zone yeah that's
that's probably that's probably the move
next time i know one of our one of our
coaches that's upstairs that does a lot
of that just quality control stuff like
yeah i should have taken a knee i'm just
like man i should just got down i was
trying to be too cute and trying to
waste too much time i should have just
immediately gone down but
defense ended up bailing us out and
getting a stop so it worked out you
looked like old school le'veon bell back
there like kind of surfing around back
there austin though right that's what
you're kind of looking for it's not a
waste time but in the end knowing now
seeing the situation if i would have
been smarter than like we had we had
three downs that we just got a first
down so i didn't even need to waste more
time
yeah that was definitely on me well i
mean
it all worked out austin that's for sure
so what what does that victory mean to
come out of a game like that
with the w
for you
yeah man i think it's just you know
shows you know just the talent this team
the consistency that we have and
you know that's been something that
we've struggled with in the past you
know i've been here for five years now
and so you know having these games i
think you know my
second year was the year that i can
compare this to where we're just
finishing games
it's not always pretty but we're on the
other side of the winning side of these
games
and it's the nfl you're going to play
hard teams you know every single week is
going to be a battle
so it comes down to being consistent
just showing hey that we can do it week
in and week out and i think you know
with coach staley he comes in with a
great plan and joe lombardi calling it
on offense and we stick to the plan and
it's been working so they got trust in
us we have trust in them and it's making
a great ecosystem for us to have
confidence in each other and go and play
as best we can no i had your comrade
joey bozon last week prior to your
monday night or against the
raiders austin and he said that um
coach staley kind of mapped out the way
the the victory against the chiefs was
going to go that you're going to get up
early they're going to make a run and
you're going to hold on late
did he make the call that there would be
a 41 point back and forth fourth quarter
in this one did he predict this one too
oh you know not quite
i'm not sure anyone predicted how that
was gonna play out right um
what a wild game like you said uh yeah
but you know that's that's football
right you know you're gonna deal with
some adversity you gotta just continue
to to continue to try to stick to a plan
that you know has been working
throughout the game and make adjustments
and you know our adjustment there was
you know what we have to score every
single time we touch the ball because
this is going to be a shootout this game
and then you know defense like i said
ended up getting a stop when we needed
the most at the end of the game well
you're a gamer austin eckler did it feel
like you were playing a video game at
some point yesterday
didn't it no man
for me man when i get the ball man it's
just i feel like i'm just very efficient
like i'm not i feel like me like i
describe myself like i'm not a flashy
running back you know but i'm efficient
with the ball in my hands and so that's
where i started racking up all these
yards you look at the end of the game
like dang he had a hundred and whatever
yards of total offense and a few
touchdowns you know um so that's just
kind of what has been for me forever you
know it's just efficiency being
efficient don't flip and fumble like i
did yesterday that that's still in my
head but um grow from that but yeah just
efficiency is the name of my game austin
eckler the los angeles chargers here on
the rich eisen show and so what you have
made yourself into right
um
is this was this the goal of what's
happening to you right now in your life
in your professional career austin yeah
you know it's it's
great that you asked that because i
think that's sometimes too just like i
never
i never knew
that i was even going to be in the nfl i
wasn't i didn't go to college thinking
i'ma go to the nfl so for me to be here
now is is incredible and it all stem it
back to just like my mindset when i
first got here and had the opportunity
to make the team
and my mindset was look this was
the most important opportunity that i
ever had in my life and so i put
literally everything into my drops my
last semester of college just to train
for my pro day and make sure i had good
numbers and i literally been putting
everything into
this sport in this game this opportunity
been growing and building upon that
ended up making the team and now grown
into a starting role and now you know
i'm trying to help these young guys get
going and now we have you know jay herb
and backfield buddies and helping him
get going so it's just been me
continuing to keep that old mindset that
i've had and just continue to apply it
year after year not not even expecting
like oh i'm gonna make a pro bowl like
i'm not even thinking about any stuff
like that i'm just really thinking about
building on being the best version
awesome that clearing at the end of the
season look up and be like all right
let's reflect and try to build on that
and now it's even grown too you know
outside of football you know as far as
just connecting getting in the community
now the foundation so trying to give
back so it's been it's been a wild
journey but i'm definitely very
fortunate for it and continuing to uh
you know push forward just with the same
mindset of hey
one opportunity leads to the next uh
before i dive into further uh with your
relationship with your backfield buddy
jay herb who you referred to him uh what
does a west colorado pro day look like
austin what is that what does that look
like here's the deal you can't have a
western colorado pro day because there's
too much snow because it's at 7 000 feet
up in the rocky mountains right
right so
you got to go to somewhere else they
don't have an indoor up there either so
i was actually at cu
um i had to go to colorado boulder to
run by pro day
so you mixed in with colorado's pro day
or is that what it was no no they didn't
they don't let you mix in but i was able
to add on after so all the colorado
people went and then there's like what
they call like the add-ins who like
perform after and then there was like 17
of us that were add-ins and then they
cut us down to two of us it was me and
the cornerback and they told everyone
else after they're 40 and they jump to
go basically go home
so yeah it's it's been
said wait a minute you had to survive a
cut on your pro day is what you're
saying
yeah
i've never heard of that before
yeah honestly
but that really had to suck that you're
like you're preparing for your pro day
it's not on your campus you have to go
to somebody else's campus and the other
campus gets done with their pro day
first then it's you and 16 other guys
that you're you're wondering which
scouts are actually going to stick
around for you and then you're told you
just did you know you had to pass a cut
was like a double was that a double
secret probation
i had no idea was gonna be cut but i ran
fast enough and jumped high and far
enough so i made
that's what matters my mou my mouth is a
gape it is truly i've never heard of
anything like this before austin oh yeah
you can imagine man imagine someone
that's you know training for protein
finally got your opportunity and you're
under 40 and you jump and you don't do
any drills you don't get to do any ball
work like you're done you don't do any
of the the mental stuff so yeah there's
definitely people that were hot you can
definitely imagine that i bet so last
one for you on this did the other guy
make it who made the cut with you on
that pro do you remember i don't even
remember i don't remember who it was
right
so no
probably not i can't believe that austin
eckler here on the rich eisen show let's
get into
uh herbert so your relationship with him
give me give me a good story what do you
got for me on this front like getting to
know him and we what you do together and
things like that you know he's he's
definitely been coming along just as far
as his leadership compared to last year
um i think that's just with
comfortability you know finding out how
the nfl works you know being in this
position where you know a lot of eyes
are on him and just you know i think
having a lot of vets around him too we
have a lot of just older guys especially
on offense uh we just welcome him in and
we know we're doing so it really takes a
lot of pressure off of him
and bringing in the center too like cory
who can really run protections and run
id points really helps just him feel
comfortable and when he feels
comfortable guess what now he's feeling
more confident now he's you know in a
better mood because he's not as much
stress on him so it's helped him build
chemistry with us and with me um like i
said i always tell him like every day
every game day like hey man i got you
back out there because i'm like the last
line of defense you know then other than
his legs so he's been coming along and
man like building some camaraderie i've
seen him you know just come more alive
in the offensive huddle too just making
sure we're on our key points just giving
giving guys hey ball security hey we're
trying to do this on this play hey be
ready for this check so just seeing him
just develop right that's you know what
you want to see in all your players but
especially in your quarterback position
especially the way he's playing so
looking forward to continuing to be his
back to a buddy for a few more seasons
yeah bosa mentioned something about
victory brisket
austin
what is that
yeah they get they got this little group
called the brisket boys
what's what is that they go
after every win um they go make
themselves a brisket they have some
traeger grill thing that they do
um
yeah okay they got a little club over
there what about you what what what club
what club do you have do you got one
man
i'm i'm always uh just trying to trying
to connect with people and get back in
the community so i got a lot of stuff
going i'm actually working on a really
big project that i'm sure i'll be on
here talking again once that develops a
little bit more towards the end of the
year but it's just a ways for me to
connect like that's what i do in my free
time it's like how can austin eclair
help other people because you see me
with like fantasy football um you know i
have a fantasy football show on yahoo
and so for me it's like like i said i
came from western colorado like this
little tiny school so i have all the
support now and i'm just so thankful for
the opportunity so it's my way of giving
back and that's kind of what i like to
do in my free time is help people
find skills learn skills about
themselves and help them become a better
version of themselves like i have been
able to um through the nfl so you don't
need their stinking brisket right i mean
if they they would invite me to brisket
you know the brisket things
gladly show up but they got their own
little little thing going so
i don't mean to divide the team i mean
everything seems to be going so well no
no we all we all got our own stuff right
i mean we're not divided we spend hours
every single week together so you know
we need a little time away well i also
you know i hear nothing but
raves from your locker room
uh about the new head coach and we
showed also him giving out game balls
after beating the raiders and if i'm not
mistaken you received one yeah after
that game yeah i got one for the raiders
game yeah
so
what does that mean yeah you get a game
ball in this coach right at the agency
and it's special you know because
well we all put so much work into this i
feel like and you know it's just a win
in general we should all like the team's
basically getting a game ball but um
to have coaches have respect and show
that respect by giving out game balls
you know that's always you know an honor
it's kind of like you know wearing that
captain on your on your on your jersey
you know but there's for an individual
games like you know you you performed
exceptionally this game uh we we need
everyone to perform but you know you
went a little above and beyond and
helped help us get the win right um so
it's always special for the game balls
for sure and uh you know they're
rightfully so given out and so yeah like
we said like you said we respect coach
staley so much just because he's proved
himself to us
um so having that honor from getting a
game ball from him is is definitely
something that you don't take lightly
and remember forever yeah kind of
awesome
sure it also helps to say you know i uh
before i got here i i was the dc for
aaron donald and i helped you know von
miller with his pass rush in denver and
i'm also a former quarterback in college
i mean he kind of touches on everything
right i mean you think about it
you know yeah man man's been been around
a lot of football and uh you can tell
that too he's super smart guy
uh you know how he breaks it down to us
you know for the team's aspect too as
far as what the game plan is is
something that i really like in his
coaching style what was it like in that
locker room yesterday after that game i
mean it has to be one of the craziest
games you've ever played anywhere at any
level
that was definitely
one of the craziest games absolutely
we're just going back and forth and back
and forth
uh and then converting on fourth down
especially on offense just like wow like
we were rolling um but yeah after the
welcome i was just in awe like i wasn't
even when i went to my press conference
then i was just in awe like
we just pulled that out like we we did
that like the los angeles chargers went
out there and actually overcame some
adversity there were of so many years
we've been like falling short you know
and it's like that wasn't an easy one
either that was a really hard one that's
like yo we're proving our team um you
know today it was just our day that day
you're on offense like hey defense were
struggling getting stops offense go
score points and we were able to do it
um so i think that says a lot about our
team right you know you know we can pick
each other up and coach daddy says it
all the time you know we have to be a
team of teams and that means hey if you
know your brother's struggling we gotta
pick him up um you know obviously we're
trying to all play as best we can and
you know try to have a definitive win
but that is the nfl so it doesn't happen
like that very often so yeah definitely
uh
taking this week you know for baltimore
and uh approaching it like hey we're
playing another great team again here we
go you know what's the plan let's go out
and practice well all starts in practice
practicing all the things we preach
every single week going into the week as
far as operation as far as being
efficient and then going out and put it
out there yeah i mean it could be a
battle of two four and one teams and uh
that might be the difference between you
potentially taking a january flight one
day to chile baltimore or you chilling
in sofi
um and so
that's my last question for you is how
prepared do you think this team is for
the expectations to be raised and being
mentioned along with the bills and the
ravens as
uh an afc
real deal combatant here for the chance
to stay in your building and play for
the super bowl
i mean i don't think there's any doubt
that you
can't have you have to have this in the
conversation a real deal like we've been
putting it out there on film actually
executing winning these games so i would
say yeah you definitely have to put us
in that conversation but you know it
comes down for a players aspect it's
week by week right like we cannot focus
on anything
beyond this week this is the week that
matters because if you don't win this
week then your conversation of
anything at the end of the season has no
relevance um so that's our mindset and
it has to be you know and it's the same
thing across the entire nfl like this is
the week that we have to come out show
it doesn't matter who you're playing you
have to win this week and you have to
continue to do that and that's that's
kind of a routine you start to get in in
the nfl and that's what you know helps
sustain when you can especially when you
get on a winning drive and you're a
winning streak okay
what we're doing what we've been doing
is working let's continue to do that you
know when you start losing that you're
like okay how do i change up my routine
how do i you know you're trying to do
new things i feel like we have a good
chemistry right now um so we're trying
to ride this wave as much and as hard as
we can every single week
well austin um you know we're fully
vaxxed uh uh spot so on your bye week in
a couple weeks if you want to come in
and tell us what's going on with your
with your organization and your
community work and whatever in person
i'd love to have you here if not we'll
take you over the phone let's do this
again real soon yeah i appreciate it
thank you rich appreciate you having me
on man right back at you congrats on
everything and just try not to score
better next time okay will you please
okay okay just gotta get better gotta
get better you never thought you'd be in
a position where you want to score but
really don't want to score and you just
gotta work out that just gotta get
better one every time thanks for the
call take care yep that's austin eckler
everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here